when I found you in the records of that
ship I considered leaving you Zack
Snider's been busy creating a brand new
Space Opera franchise and now he's ready
to share it with the world here's
everything you need to know before you
go to your couch to see Rebel Moon part
one a child of fire what do you think
they
want everything let's talk about who
made it it pretty much begins and ends
with Zack Snyder like not even
exaggerating he directed produc did the
cinematography co-wrote the screenplay
and is credited for the story I mean if
this man also did the accounting on the
film I would not be surprised actually I
probably would anyways of course we all
know that Zack Snyder knows a thing or
two about big budget franchise type
stuff I mean he previously directed
films like 300 and Watchmen before his
long and impactful stint with the DCU
and of course we cannot forget his gig
doing music videos for bands like My
Chemical Romance I'm so sorry I had to
throw that in there but fun fact My
Chemical Romance are actually big comic
book fans and they actually covered a
Bob Dylan song for Watchmen it's so good
anyways the other two screenplay writers
are Kurt johnstad for movies like 300
and atomic blonde and Shay Hatton from a
couple John Wick flicks the director
also teamed up with Tom hulkenberg to do
the music and he actually scored P
Snider films like Batman v Superman dawn
of Justice and Zack Snider's Justice
League so the rebel moon is in good
hands but what exactly is it you might
and should be asking well it comes from
ideas that have been bouncing around
Snider's head since he was 12 and it
actually draws inspiration from the
works of Akira kurasawa heavy metal
magazines and of course Star Wars movies
in fact it began its development Journey
as a more mature Star Wars film that
Zach had actually pitched to Lucas film
back when Disney first took over in 2012
he also pitched it as a video game/
movie franchise to Warner Brothers a
couple times too before eventually
landing at Netflix as far as The Story
Goes we know the universe it's set in is
controlled by the corrupt government of
the mother World meanwhile a peaceful
settlement on a distant moon has become
threatened by the mother world's Army
called the Imperium but hope is found in
one mysterious villager and former
Imperium member known as Kora and she's
tasked with putting together similar
Warriors to help fight for their cause
and speaking of Kora let's talk about
who is actually starring in this so
bringing the story to live on screen is
a rather talented cast starting with the
star and the total badass from the
trailers Sophia boutella as Kora the
dancer turned actress has had some
bigger roles that you might recognize
like blade legs lady in the first
Kingsman film or princess amonette in
Tom Cruz's version of the mummy and much
like Snyder she has a strong music video
resume too that includes artists like
Madonna Rihanna Neo MJ and food Fighters
I mean that's an insane resume so her
character recruits a ragtag team of
Fighters played by a bunch of familiar
faces friends like gon hunu Charlie
hunam Jenna Malone and Ray Fisher
there's a bunch of others too but
research shows that video editors hate
list of names now on the villain side
one of the main baddies is Ed scrine who
also played the villain in Deadpool and
he's playing the leader of the Imperium
Army in Rebel Moon some other faces
you'll know include Cory stall and
Carrie elz and you'll also hear the
voice of Anthony Hopkins and if you're
missing his face already like I am just
refer to his dancing videos on his
Instagram okay let's talk about the
future now because uh that's where my
anxiety causes me to live this movie is
hopefully just a beginning for Zack
Snider and friends and to ensure that
this is more than just a one and done
flick all kinds of media is in motion
for this already along with adding a
part one to the title to make sure we
know more is coming things like multiple
video games an animated short a graphic
novel a novelization of the film a
prequel comic a narrative podcast and
even plans for a TV series focusing on
the main villain are all in the works I
mean should I add part one to the
beginning of all my relationships just
to ensure this type of devotion I mean
this is wild plus we know that the movie
Rebel Moon Part Two The scarg Giver is
actually already scheduled for release
in April of next year so for more on
that we of course will see you right
back here in a few months all right my
friends it's everything you need to know
before you go see Rebel Moon part one a
child of fire on Netflix December 22nd
thanks for watching and be sure to rate
and review this film at Rotten
tomatoes.com
[Music]